Raise your hand, and be honest, if
you've used the phrase "crazy busy"
to describe your day,
your week,
yourmonth.
I'm an emergency-room doctor,
and "crazy busy" is a phrase
you will never hearme use.
Step one to go from Crazy Mode to
Ready Mode is to relentlessly triage.
In CrazyMode, you're always
busy, always stressed,
because you're reacting to every
challenge withthe same response.
Contrast that with Ready
Mode, where we triage,
which means we prioritize
by degree of urgency.
Red -- immediately life-threatening.
Yellow -- serious, but not
immediately life-threatening.
Green -- minor.
And we focus our efforts
first on the reds.
Sostart by triaging correctly.
Know your reds.